Roberto starts us off this hour in
Springfield Missouri hi Roberta how are
you hi Dave and thank you for this
opportunity sure what the deal is is we
are in our 60s we have a place that is a
lot a lot of equity but we will have to
downsize in the near future and I
thought if we found the place we wanted
to move to to get a reverse mortgage to
pay for that I'll just sell the other
place and then sell the other place and
then pay off the reverse mortgage and
the new place will be paid for why don't
you just sell it before you buy move
down well then I'm in between and I I
don't know where I would live and I hate
to move to an apartment and storage
units and this way I could kind of take
my time and look for something I want
and then take a and then I gotta give me
time to sell the other place so what's
your current place worth about 265,000
how hard will it be to sell uh it this
uh it's it's really hard to say in this
part of the area in the Ozarks some
places sell fast others have been for
sale for several years
but we we do have a really good talk um
the curb appeal so I think it would sell
pretty decent we only old $53,000 you
have other money yes we have 401 but
that's part of our income month-to-month
with retirement pension 401k or security
that's our income and how much is in
your 401 but between the two of us about
five hundred thousand okay cool and when
you move down what would you pay for the
place you'd move down to about a hundred
and fifty thousand okay all right and
you pay cash for that are you would you
would clear the two hundred out of your
other place you're saying okay yeah well
you don't want to use a reverse mortgage
in this situation a reverse mortgage is
a situation where you get paid payments
monthly that doesn't give you a lump sum
you need a lump sum you need a lump sum
of a hundred and fifty thousand
yes yes and so what you'd have to do is
just go get a mortgage okay of two
hundred thousand to pay off the first
mortgage and put hundred and fifty in
your pocket and you probably just do
that at the credit union we used to
would call this and the credit union
might still call it this a bridge loan
where you're bridging between this
property and the next one that is I'm so
glad I called you this it's wonderful
now that the deal is this I I would
prefer that you put your property how
hard is it going to be for you to locate
where you want to move when your cells
well it's going to be about four or five
hours away where I want to move to and
but I've got family over there that can
kind of be looking for our next place so
that will help okay well what I would do
is a couple things um personally I
wouldn't I wouldn't go that route that
would be my worst-case scenario is what
we just laid out with a bridge loan
instead I would get pretty serious about
when is it you want to move pretty soon
I mean if you found the place today and
your place was sold would you move no it
did have to be in maybe about five years
why what's happening during the next
five years uh my husband would be old
enough out where he can fully retire
also he's working there still he's got a
part-time job he really likes and he
wants to do that for a few more years to
make it Social Security a little better
when he retires what does he do I truck
driver I don't have truck drivers at the
other city oh well but this is a
part-time and it really fits like a
glove
and uh it'd be risky going to another
place and then winding up where you have
to work full-time or over the road this
is my you don't have to do anything
you've got enough money you don't have
to do anything well that's that's true
so how old is he he'll be 62 in May okay
all right I mean whatever you want to do
is fine my preference would be when
you're ready to move within six months
of the time you're ready to move I would
start concentrating very heavily on
making trips over to the other city and
looking at properties there when you
find one you like I would put an offer
on it
contingent upon the sale of yours run
home and put yours up for sale and see
if you could get your sold and just
close one right into the other sometimes
that let those dominoes line up and work
and then if that particular property
gets away that might be okay you might
go look for another one or if you want
to do your bridge loan to keep it from
getting away at some point you could but
my preference would be you get your
house all dolled up and shined up and
ready to go
you get the realtor all lined up and so
when you say go go and you start talking
about putting it on the market in the
meantime you head over and start
shopping and find a property and make an
offer on it and it's a simple
contingency contract that's done in
every city and it's contingent upon the
make an offer on the new property and
the you're not obligated to buy the new
property unless your sells contingent
upon the sale of yours and that way you
don't get that way you don't get pinched
and you just do the whole thing with
cash and it's not a borrowed there's
nine borrowed money involved that way if
that property is going to get away and
you're dying over it and you did a
bridge loan it's not the end of the
world you're just going to pay some
pretty healthy payments though until
yours gets your old property gets sold
and it the problem is it kind of turns
you into a motivated seller because
you're staring down the barrel of a
$2,000 a month payment you're going man
I want rid of this thing and all of a
sudden you start cutting the price and
you don't maximize what you could have
done because you got yourself back into
debt and so it's not my plan I wouldn't
do that but it's a way around it and
certainly you don't need a reverse
mortgage thanks for the call hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you are
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own youtube
channel yes that's right kind of
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you